this is the first time where content can
actually go viral on every single
platform and you don't have to write or
film a video for Facebook film a 12
minute video for YouTube film a sub 60
second video for tick tock write a tweet
for Twitter and post this on Reddit you
can just do the same thing on every
platform and the fact that your content
has gone viral on multiple platforms
regularly means that
virality is not accidental or sometimes
it can be of course but it's it's just
it can be engineered it's yeah so many
people say it's luck and they're like
you're just lucky or this or that but
what are we up to probably like a
thousand videos over 10 million views
like we don't ever have a dud like you
can call it luck but I think it could be
trained I I counsel YouTubers all the
time and show them how to go from
getting a couple million views a month
to 10 million views a month very easily
if I'm even certain ones like
just one of my friends like he was just
really struggling and so I just started
showing him basically everything I know
and just doing like once every week
sometimes once every two weeks calls and
he went from ten thousand dollars a
month on YouTube to over 400 000. just
doing these little counseling calls and
so I mean people can make excuses all
they want and say it's just luck or say
you know
um well anyways I don't even want to
quote all the other stuff but it's just
it is it is a teachable skill it's a
learnable skill you can study your way
to consistently make viral videos no
matter how small your channel is even if
you have zero subscribers you could if
if you actually studied hard enough and
like basically if you knew what I knew
and some of these so I don't sound so
arrogant also like some of these other
friends that have that I'd say are the
smartest people in the world when it
comes to content creation online if you
had the knowledge that was in our heads
you could do it very easily I see people
do it all the time
um and what's even more interesting is I
go on podcasts and I say everything I
know and these people are also very open
some of them I know it's all out there
and a lot of people instead of just
studying that and trying to absorb and
apply it in their own way they're just
like no it's just luck you know so you
do lay it all out there but I gotta push
back to one interesting thing I think a
crucial component of your success is the
idea stage the idea generation the
brainstorm I heard today but getting
really good at generating ideas so it's
not it's not just
the uh the selection of the thumbnail
and the title that creative process it's
also just the the engine of generating
really good ideas of course and getting
that I mean I I would say that is
probably the thing that needs to be
trained the most for most creators right
that they're they just don't put enough
ideas on paper yes but also a lot of
creators also just don't
you know which I didn't either for the
longest time just didn't don't make good
enough content you know content that's
worthy of getting 10 million views in
the idea or the execution of the idea
both I mean like think about how many
people just make videos they film in
under 20 minutes and they don't really
put any effort into it and like you know
it's like my first 500 videos didn't
deserve to get a million views like
there's a reason they did they're
terrible you know but at the time I
thought they did right now I'm in the
mindset of a lot of small YouTubers or I
thought those videos deserved a million
views and I thought the algorithm hated
me but I watched them back now and I can
tell you exactly why the videos was
[ __ ] horrible you know what I mean
well so what was the Breakthrough for
you to start realizing to start having a
self-awareness you know about these
videos aren't good enough you're
probably still going through that you're
probably still growing to see like yeah
every six months you should look back
and hate your videos or at least see
things you could improve and be like oh
I could have done this better that
better if not then you're not learning
quick enough in my opinion at least
where's the source of that learning even
for you now it's uh just looking I just
got back from them I mean I just got
back from a mastermind where I just got
like you know 10 of the smartest people
I knew and we just locked ourselves in a
cabin and taught each other's stuff um
constantly every day not every day now
probably every other day I go on a walk
and I just call random people I'll just
say teach me something and uh I mean
it's just uh you just have to have a
never-ending thirst for Learning Link
that's very imperative especially if you
want like if you want to get on top and
then stay on top the only way to do it
is just to constantly be learning or
someone who is learning is just gonna
you know have a leg up on you in the
knowledge game and what kind of stuff
are you because you you've talked about
Offline that you just love learning of
all kinds it doesn't matter but in terms
of videos are you studying videos are
you studying recently not as much I'm
more because to get to the videos I want
I have to build this business and scale
up and hire so one of my recent time has
been like my teenage years were spent
studying virality and studying content
creation Now I'm studying how to build a
Content company so I can actually
produce the crazy ideas I want to
produce if that makes any sense